I really want to go bedroom he like can
I go bedroom okay they tell me code and
I'm coming like two bedroom all gender
all gender is like what is this where I
have to
go first time I said like I stopped like
is it true what he's saying that there's
a direct targeting of Muslim children
are you seeing this 100% Cinder born as
a school board meeting is shut down
early by the fire marshal it was a scene
of absolute pandemonium of the Dearborn
school board meeting this evening
hundreds of parents came out we will get
to all of those stories in just a moment
but first our top story tonight a
samamish city leader resigns following
his comments against the LBGTQ
[Music]
Community people to get educated on
polygyny for example you think they'd
allow this in the schools no way no no
way alhamdulillah brothers and sisters
we've acquired the future Dean Center
property and we want to get the mashid
open first it's all coming along we're
installing the doors we can make woo
we've installed the carpets we have many
details to finish up but it's coming
along alhamdulillah we need a new roof
we need new windows and we need a minbar
that's right we need a minbar for the
Masid now if all of you want to be a
part of history and help build a house
of worship build a Masjid for the sake
of Allah so Allah the Creator can build
for you a house in Jenna click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of
you
alhamdulillah greetings of Peace how you
guys doing it's good to have you with us
here imagine sending your child to go
learn reading and math and then next
thing you know looks like they're
looking at a book of pornography you
would say what yeah it's becoming
something that's part of the curriculum
and you have Muslims and Christians
coming together and other people of
Consciousness and this is a tragedy for
some some are getting very upset about
it because people are speaking out and
they're using that freedom of speech
that we have to peacefully speak out so
we're going to be with somebody here
today I have a guest who's on the front
lines he's going to bring us up to speed
on what's happening with this
sexualization of the children the
Muslims and Christians coming together
to work together on this with my next
guest she Mustafa
Omar let me in you to my face
we have God his name
Allah and his final Messengers muhamad
peace be upon him this is our religion
Islam Islam this is the
de I love you work you're doing when I
was ready to talk about it I would only
talk to you I was explaining how much
respect I have for the faith of
Islam to
theum how you been I've been pretty good
how was ulah you just came back from
Bosnia I just came back from Bosnia it
was a great trip uh you had some chap
some BUDK some clava I did I did
fantastic food really nice people uh lot
of lessons to learn historical lessons
some great and some very
sad some very sad you visited also uh
the
C area there we saw the building we saw
the graves we saw the buildings in
mostar that had been bombed and shelled
right next to our fourstar hotel there's
a building that's completely demolished
uh from the you know blockade that was
taking place so when you learn about
that history that happened ' 92 to 95
it's uh it's crazy there's so many
lessons to to learn but you can when you
witness it and you see it it really it
hits home it goes to your heart this is
like the the um Jerusalem of Europe
exactly Bosnia would you agree exactly
exactly and you know people were
witnessing and watching this on TV they
saw sevo being surrounded literally
people are crossing the street and
they're being sniped in a in a modern
contemporary City with with cameras you
know being broadcast on the news all
around the world and it took 3 years for
anyone to even do anything United
Nations stood by and pretty much did
nothing so it's a pretty sad incident in
the history of the modern world I don't
know if you've heard of the reporter
investigative journalist CJ willerman if
you've heard of in uh he did a report
that they were doing safari hunting and
it's one that has been kept completely
hidden from View for the past 30 years
that is until now that is until a former
US government official came forward
recently to testify that wealthy Western
tourists paid Bosnian Serb army forces
for access to shoot Muslims in sovo when
the city was Under Siege during the
early 1990s making this the kind of
human Safari that you see only in a
dystopian Hollywood movie but the horror
that happened in Bosnia was no
screenplay it was real and these Grizzly
details have been revealed in the soon
to be released documentary sovo
Safari
you know people Safari hunt for animals
so according to him um he looked into
this and he had some witnesses and
whatnot uh I saw this report that he did
that people were flying in from other
countries and just like you how you're
describing you have Sao it's surrounded
right yeah so people are coming so for
people that know safari hunting this is
where you go to South Africa or places
and and you're going to shoot down the
animals they're hunting humans and there
people are paying to go ahead and snipe
Muslims this is insanity this is this is
when you know people have literally gone
above and beyond any type of basic
humanity and
Consciousness at all yeah Subhan Allah
it's crazy and I usually recommend
people because they travel here there
everywhere to uh put it on your
destination go to Bosnia huh would
absolutely for sure for sure it's it's
uh it's not that expensive it's
beautiful place has clean water clean
they said the cleanest water cleanest
air best forest in Europe you got
Islamic history there you got your halal
food you got Muslims there and there's
so much important history to learn
modern and and and In classical history
beautiful country yeah I'm not just
saying that because that's where my
family's from but when you were just
there and reminded me of it we're
talking about it and uh I really like
when people go and they experience that
you get to hear the van you're you're
around it's so beautiful man see the old
mids feel the aan see you know see the
people it's it's really really amazing
beautiful so another thing how bring us
on the speed there's a there's a lot
going on now uh with this whole movement
it seems like you were you were talking
about this um individual green what's
his name Glen Greenwald Gren Greenwald
Glenn Greenwall yeah is one of the main
uh people behind The Intercept uh news a
big deal is investigative reporter who
himself is gay yeah I mean he was
talking about recently he had a clip
about how the the rainbow movement has
just gotten completely out of hand
because now they're in a position of
power and he was basically making the
point that when people are in positions
of power and authority they begin to go
and oppress those people who are in
weaker positions so it's easy when
you're not in the position of power to
say like you know what look at these
people who are in power they're
oppressing all of us but then when you
get in a position of authority and power
you start doing the same thing and this
is exactly what's happening with the
movement and when it's gotten taken it's
been taken too far when it's basically
the idea to that you must accept this
type of behavior this life type of
Lifestyle you must accept it as being a
normal uh manifestation of you know
humanity and you're forced to accept
that and if you don't then you're going
to be penalized for it that's an abuse
and a misuse of power and that's what's
happening today I just want to make a
disclaimer because obviously we're in
America you know pretty much uh you're
you're a learning man there's a thing
called what freedom of uh religion yes
and freedom of speech freedom of speech
so we're not calling towards any
violence or not at all anything that
would be breaking any kind of laws we're
just informing practicing these two
things freedom of religion freedom of
speech this part of the Constitution
right exactly yeah exactly uh so I just
wanted to make that disclaimer yeah and
I wanted you to get your opinion because
this goes into what we're talking about
Dearborne as a school board meeting is
shut down early by the fire marshal it
was a scene of Absol absolute
pandemonium of the Dearborn school board
meeting this evening as hundreds of
parents came out to protest a handful of
books that are in the school libraries
books that some parents say are
pornographic it's called this book is
gay by Junoon and it has some uh like
chapter N9 the ins and outs of gay sex
decorum was lost inside the scoreboard
meeting as parents yelled and screamed
demanded to be heard that's when the
fire marshal stepped in is it true what
he's saying that there's a direct
targeting of Muslim children are you
seeing this 100% 100% not like 90% 80%
this is 100% I was informed about this
in California in my local school
district Santa Ana and Anaheim School
District where we have a lot of uh
Muslim refugees coming from different
countries some of them their native
language is not even English so they
have uh they speak you know uh they're
from Afghanistan so they speak PTO or
whatever other languages they're from
Syria so they speak Arabic and what
happen happened was one of my friends a
Christian friends she forwarded me she's
a teacher in the school district so she
forwarded me Brenda she's been on your
your your show before Brenda liac yeah
Brenda leback so she forwarded me years
ago this is years ago a curriculum for
the school system which is basically in
Arabic in PTO in all these different
languages that Muslims are speaking and
it's talking about how yeah you might
have heard you know someone might have
told you that like in the Quran it talks
you know it's against homosexual uality
or saying that it's sinful you shouldn't
do it but that's actually that's
actually not true and they start quoting
verses from the Quran to like twist it
around and justifi in the native
language so you know you don't even have
that you didn't even have that stuff in
English yet and it's already being
translated into Arabic into PTO in into
like different languages where they're
clearly targeting the Muslim Community
and I think the reason why they're doing
that is because people who are coming
from those countries they have a a good
foundation of like Islamic ethics in
them and they're like well we need to
get to these people we need to get to
their kids very quickly before they can
you know say something or do something
or whatever it is so it is a definitely
a brainwashing campaign that has been
planned out for years and it's been
launched actually in California for
years and now we're starting to see it
in all the other states so I'm getting
I'm getting news reports from from
Muslims and in every other state that
say Hey this is what's happening now I'm
like well this is what's been happening
in California for the past five years
six years maybe even 10
years uh is is the Alli are the
alliances growing now with with
Christians and Muslims Christians who
are fed up with this I know Patrick Ben
David he was actually trying to get
Muslims this is what I like he was going
in a really good direction he was had
some um Christian higher up on his
program and he was talking about okay
let's let's look past some of the
differences but there's not too many I
mean there are some obviously we don't
believe you know that Jesus is God Son
of God there's only one God okay we
don't have to get into to all that right
now we can get the elephant out of the
room right exactly Muslims believe in
pure monotheism and we love Jesus and uh
etc etc um that's out of the way now
let's save the kids exactly so he was
kind of saying the similar thing exactly
are we seeing this now Brenda lipsa is
is a good example of that she's a
Christian she's somebody who's been on
the program before yes yes we're we're
we're exactly seeing this and you know
after 911 there was uh you know uh
discrimination there was islamophobia
kind of like there was a suspicion
against Muslims by especially the
Christian right we're seeing that now
we're seeing this as an opportunity for
kind of changing this entire thing
around and I'm seeing this happening so
at school board meetings we have Muslims
and Christians both speaking up and
sometimes the Muslims are are the most
vocal ones at the board meetings and I
have like Christian my Christian friends
are reaching out and saying like you
know what you guys are you guys are like
role models for us you know like the way
in which you're addressing this issue uh
the way in which you're concerned for
your kids we're so happy we wish we
would see even more from the community
we need to work together uh I had uh
there was this new navigating
differences document that came out from
many scholars and everything uh one of
my uh Christian friends reached out and
said you know what I wish we had
something like this from the Christian
church or all the different churches
kind of got together and signed it I
wish one of my rabbis friends told me I
wish we had something where we could
have like 200 rabbis sign a document
saying hey this is what we State about
you know uh homosexuality about gender
non-conformity these are our principles
and this is where we don't compromise
and this is where we draw the line I
wish we had something like that so
people are looking at the Muslim
Community and saying wow like you know
these guys really have taken the next
step and I I think that's because for
some reason I think Muslims are very I
think they're a little bit extra
concerned about what's going to happen
to their children and now that the
children you know most Muslims have have
always been a little bit concerned about
this from even an adult perspective but
now you're talking about your kids you
know and Muslims are very the family
values are very strong so it's like
someone's doing this to your kids it's
like listen man you're going to
discriminate against me you're going to
say some bad stuff about me okay you
know I'm going to I'm going to stand up
I'm going to say some stuff but you do
that to my kids you've crossed a red red
line now I'm not going to be quiet now I
need to speak up now this is way too far
you don't mess with my kids and that's
what I'm seeing
happening uh and I think Christians um
and others they're seeing Muslims who
are not afraid some are but more are
coming out we have more of a stance
against this like um recently you had
also the Patrick M David he had khabib
he was interviewing khabib and then he
asked khabib how many genders are
there
like
here is like I see only woman and men
there is no no between got it got
[Applause]
it you
know he has khib that and and then
khabib obviously gave him a a direct
answer um and he kind of broke it down
he gave a nice story but when he was
going to the bathroom and now he was
trying to figure out which one to go
into and he had to
knock couple weeks ago and I wasn't
California I was like on coffeee shop he
like I really want to go bedroom he's
like can I go bedroom okay they told me
Cod and I'm coming like two bedroom all
gender all gender is like what is this
where I have to
go first time I said like I sto like I I
I st like 5 Second there
like where's woman where's
man I lock the
door anybody
inside
okay it's like I don't know but uh so
they they they respect that it's kind of
something that um but what do you
suggest because over time people get
desensitized right yep you keep you if
people don't speak up what's that
statement that if good people do nothing
this is this is when um evil can spread
exactly exactly and that's very similar
to a statement of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he said that anyone
who sees some evil or sees something
wrong happening you know they should fix
it with their hand if they're able to
you know in the right way legally and
all that stuff but if you can't you're
not able to do that then you fix it with
your tongue meaning you got to speak out
against it you got to say something
because if no one says anything or no
one does anything or if it doesn't even
bother you in your heart then it's like
how's Society going to change who's
who's going to who's going to uh you
know correct these things yeah so yeah
we have to do that is it because there's
funding because obviously even people at
these board meetings when people have
gotten up and they start to read from
some of these books the explicit details
of you know the penetration and then
showing even showing on in the news
reports when they go to show this uh the
private genitalia of the male the female
and them getting into action and whatnot
the news media they'll blur this out uh
or they'll tell the person who's at the
board meeting speaking out of the
details that in some of these books and
then they'll tell them to stop so you'll
tell them to stop at the board meeting
and then you also blur this out on TV
but then you expect for the little minds
of children to go ahead and be exposed
to this
evil exactly you uh what what what what
are the arguments what what are the
other side of arguments to excuse some
of this what are they saying basically I
mean there you know their explanation is
oh well this is the reality of what's
happening right so this is this is
simply what what people do and since it
exists then we should just go ahead and
expose the children to it it's a false
argument because it's it's like saying
you know what okay pornography exists in
the world but does that mean you're
going to be like oh because it exists in
the world should we show it to Children
you know should we even show it to the
average adult did you put on put on
public television that's not the way
that it works because you know there's
there's uh there's so many crimes
there's so many bad things that happen
in the world do you want to go and like
explicitly show this to every single
person and like flash it in front of
them it's going to go into their mind
it's going to go into their heart and
then it becomes something that's
completely normalized for them so that's
that's a very weak argument right I
think there's just double standards the
double standards is that you know what
there's so many other things which
you'll censor out you're not going to
allow children to use foul language in
your classroom right and at the same
time people use a lot of bad language
they use a lot of bad words so do you
put in the in the kindergarten book do
you put in like the the little book
about you know the Bears coming and like
visiting the household are they cussing
each other out with the FW and all that
stuff you don't see that you say well
that's part of reality too why do you
censor that you censor it because you
know that's not appropriate for children
let alone being appropriate for adults
but yeah exists in the world but we're
like no we don't we don't want our kids
to to learn that behavior because then
they're going to think it's normal if
Little Bear cusses out the other you
know baby bear or father Bear Mama Bear
or whatever it is then the kids are
going to start imitating that so they're
like we don't want that to happen but
when you start showing the same thing
you see like you know male bear coming
and getting married to another male bear
you don't think that's going to also
normalize it for them and they're like
well this is I can go ahead and do this
you know so that's exactly what the
agenda is but it's a very double
standard hypocritical agenda and that's
where we need to you know we need to
call that part out how did it even get
so far did you got to a point where you
know and we talked about this before but
for the people who sometimes they don't
think but it's just so obvious like uh
you need to be certain age to go to the
military to get a tattoo you need your
parents permission even to get a
passport you need to have two parents
there uh and the list goes on for
R-rated movie explicit need an adult and
driver's license Alcohol Tobacco you
need to be a certain age
but now they're pushing this on the kids
with the puberty blockers they're
pushing this thing on with children now
at a young age getting indoctrinated and
they want to hit them just at that right
ripe age so then they can go ahead and
you know help them to make the
transition that transitioning now and
they're making it illegal is it that
somebody what do they call it this um
conversion therapy yeah if you want to
talk to someone out of it but you can
yeah it's not the best it's not the
right term but that that's the
pejorative term when they want attack it
they call it conversion therapy you know
even reparative therapy so you're not
allowed to use that word but basically
it's somebody who says you know I these
are my thoughts that I have and I don't
want to have these thoughts right and
say well you're not allowed to do that
so if you have the thoughts that are in
line with having gender dysphoria then
your thoughts are encouraged if you have
thoughts and say well I don't want to I
don't want to uh change into a different
gender but I'm having these thoughts can
you help me remain where I am and the
answer is like no that'll be like
conversion therapy like in the 1950s
they used to shock people or whatever no
one does that anymore right but no it's
it's it's banned and it's illegal and
you know you're looked down upon and we
can't help you in that we we can help
you transition we can't help you
detransition after you've transitioned
and we can't help you remain there if
these are kind of the feelings that you
have or even give you any advice
whatever you decide whatever you want
even if you're a little kid whatever you
feel like you go with your feelings you
in Islam we call that you know your
desires you're your haah right so it's
like do whatever you feel like and I
think that's part one root cause of the
problem you know second root cause of
the problem which you know you might
have been alluding to is there's a lot
of money there's a lot of money in
operations there's a lot of money in
hormones there's a lot of money in you
know you're going to be on a hormone
therapy for the rest of your life you
know so uh follow the money huh follow
if you follow the money the boards now
in these schools who are allowing the
books and everything do they get a
certain amount of funding at at the same
time so now there's also money involved
I would I I I'm not sure but nothing
would surprise me because if you look at
the economic meltdown that happened 2008
2009 it it came out late like much later
that uh you know these Harvard
professors uh of Economics were being
paid by the corporations uh to say that
you know this type of practice you know
is allowed of you know derivatives and
you know U modifying uh what these uh
you know mortgages are worth are not
worth whatever so there's a lot of a lot
of this stuff happens in history and
then we find out about it later so it
wouldn't surprise me if something like
this came out I think there's also a lot
of pressure on politicians on school
teachers from the power structure which
is which is dominated by the rainbow
movement now that if you don't accept
this then you're a you're a homophobe
you're a transphobe you're a this you're
discriminating uh you're just like
you're you're equivalent to being a
racist basically today and
and we're going to expose you and we're
going to cancel you and we're going to
destroy your life we're going to destroy
your family and it's like there's
there's a lot of threats taking place so
I think a lot of people are just very
afraid to do anything to say anything
even if they have in their heart they're
like yeah this is probably not good for
kids but I can't risk my whole career or
I can't risk my whole you know
everything that I'm doing so people are
really afraid and I think that fear uh
from from people who have just like a
just General understanding of of how
humans should be that fear is is
contributing to this problem have you
had any doctors now that because if you
look at a person's DNA uh you had um you
guys had at your mid not too long ago
you were actually speaking about this
you had a you had a medical doctor there
also talking from a the scientific
perspective you were you guys are really
covering all the different um uh Avenues
on this have you had doctors who had to
um now because again your religion
preaches opposite to it right so now in
this situation have you had because
you're somebody who's um you're also the
the head of the um religious you're the
Imam of the Islamic uh Center of uh
Irvine so have any medical doctors come
to you say I'm I'm in a tight position I
could lose my my uh my job get all the
time or you do this is not this is not
new this is uh eight years maybe n maybe
10 10 more than 10 years uh yeah they
many many doctors have come especially
endocrinologists who are you know they
issue hormones uh they prescribe
hormones I have pharmacists that come to
me and say hey we are you know we're
we're people come and pick up their
prescription uh of the hormones am I
allowed to sell to them what if I didn't
write the prescription should I give it
to them I don't know what they're using
it for if I know what they're using it
for it's happening all the time and what
happened was like several years ago at
least in California there was a new no
opt out policy so in the beginning like
over a decade ago uh doctors could opt
out and they could say listen this is
against my religious beliefs I cannot
perform this surgery uh for you know
gender change you know outward change or
whatever it is I cannot do this uh sex
sex reassignment surgery but then the
insurance companies came and said hey
you're not allowed to opt out anymore
and and this is where the problem lies
so you're not allowed to opt out on many
things so doctors are not all to opt out
on something even if they say this goes
against my religious values counselors
therapists are not allowed to opt out
and say listen I cannot um you know like
if if if a gay married couple comes to
you and says listen you know I am a
family therapist this is my training but
like you know I can't this is not my
field to like really help a gay couple
because this is uh you know the idea of
you know gay a gay couple is not within
my my religious values the you you're
going to be penalized if you try to opt
out and you can't get a religious
exemption to this so it's very strange
because there's there's a level of
hypocrisy it is very state byst state
but there's a level of hypocrisy in
society so like for example
Catholics uh are against abortion this
is pretty clear so there's there's laws
where Catholic doctors can opt out of
Performing abortions by saying hey this
is against our religion so you know
whatever you whatever the state's going
to do and r and whatever happened and
everything this is something that goes
against our religion we're going to do
all the other aspects of our medical job
very well we were good at what we do but
this is not something that we're going
to do and they have opt out Clauses in
in different states and all that stuff
but when it comes to something like this
you're not allowed to opt out it doesn't
matter what your religion says you're
not allowed to opt you're not allowed to
opt out that's you said that's a new
this is this is fairly new within the
last decade and more and more laws are
being passed about no opting out for
anything related to the alphabet rainbow
movement whatever whatever you want to
describe it as so everything from the
medical profession from the psychology
profession from your children uh
receiving this education you know being
taught this in schools there there's
every state there's there's battles for
there will be no opt out policy so what
happens to a Muslim doctor or Christian
Doctor Who now has a patient in front of
him and that patient wants to uh remove
their genitalia it's a it's a male and
he wants to remove the genitalia for
this purpose for the most part opt outs
are they can write they can request
something and for the most part it's
going to be denied so what ends up
happening is they're going to have to
figure out some other excuse of not
being able to do it and then they come
and they decide you know what I need to
switch into a different field I can't
remain in this particular I need to
switch into you know Internal medicine
DO go against Freedom religion
absolutely it does so so then have have
certain medical doctors fought against
this and see this is the thing is we
don't have uh doctors are naturally very
busy people right so they would like to
fight but here's the second problem the
second problem is the people who are
generally going to fight for things like
this are going to be politically
connected or activist type people and
the problem is most activists tend to be
very left leaning even in the Muslim
Community so they're not going to really
they're not going to take this on very
seriously this is not one of their
things that they're going to be like you
know what I'm going to sacrifice my
extra time and I'm going to put a lot of
effort into it let me get all the Muslim
doctors and Catholic doctors and uh
latterday Saints Mormon doctors and
Jewish doctors and and let's let's let's
do something about this and let's rally
you know Washington DC or the court or
whatever we don't find that because
sadly uh many Muslim activists and many
activists in general are left leaning
and so they're not supporting these
causes because they're kind of okay with
these cause or they support these causes
and that's the problem so you got a
basically doctor by himself doesn't have
any other support doesn't know you know
how to deal with these things doesn't
know deal with activism what is he
supposed to do M it's a challenge you
have an example here we'll show this
real quick clip of a Planning Commission
meeting and this hit the news we had a
Muslim I guess he was exposed to some
sensitivity training and they mixed it
in with race and whatnot and this is
what he had to say and he put his career
on the line pretty much we will get to
all of those stories in just a moment
but first our top story tonight samam
City leader resigns following his
comments against the LBGTQ community and
hopefully I don't want I'm not trying to
insult anybody or trying to Pro you know
praise anybody but um it's feedback
based on the conversation that we had
with regard to the training that we had
with regard to diversity so as my
background as a Muslim person um uh it
is my duty in my belief to speak uh or
to promote goodness and when when I see
certain things that are not uh
appropriate and not right to at least
speak about it so this verse in the
Quran says all mankind oh people it is
not oh Muslims or all Christians or or
Jews or oh men or oh women oh mankind
all mankind verily we have created you
from a male and a female and we have
made you into Nations and tribe so that
you get to know each other not so that
you despise each other and hate each
other and fight so you get to know each
other so part of our the creation is
that we are here to get to know each
other to learn from each other so which
is really a good thing and specifically
people we created certain ways but then
to
Club certain people who choose a certain
lifestyle and say they are among the
minority I don't believe that is the
right thing and I'm going to be very
specific the LGBT community
and specifically creating a pride month
for them these are some of the most
wealthy the most connected people I had
a person who reported to me at Microsoft
he left Microsoft for a job to be an
activist in that community that pays
double what he was making at Microsoft
so these are not a minority people who
are uh um uh disenfranchise and now we
need to Club them as part of the
minority people so in my opinion
these are people that are promoting um
diseases and uh infestation into the
mind of our kids in schools so we as a
community we should stand up for this
and that's my belief and that's where I
come from that I don't believe this is
the right way of life God created us a
male and a female and to go and go
against the creation of God and to
spread diseases in the community is is
something that we should speak up
against or at least I would like to
speak up against because that goes
against my belief so that's one what I
would like to share I believe in
diversity this is my life I believe I
love the diverse community in samamish
but if someone wants to choose a
lifestyle that's to themselves they
decide on themselves they do it
privately that's theirs but to go and
make it a a thing to promote this in
every movie in every TV show everywhere
teaching our kids and poisoning our kids
with this I don't believe this is the
right thing to do so I appreciate the
time that I was given and I wanted to
share my opinion on this so this is uh
Wasim fed and we'd like to if anybody
knows uh the um this uh brother we'd
like to invite him uh on the program put
us in touch with him what do you think
of um this uh individual Muslim he got
up and he's um he quoted some Quran mhm
at a board meeting given his time and I
guess he's kind of practicing again his
freedom of speech then he was forced to
resign yeah yeah it's sad I mean he's
definitely very brave you know and and
it's good that you know people need to
be brave you know you can say that you
know he made one or two errors in the
way he used the word disease or whatever
it is but if you just look at it
generally number one he spoke very
calmly he spoke very rationally and he
was and he said like this is my view and
this is my opinion and I love diversity
and everything so it was actually a very
it was it was Brave of him to say it for
the most part what he said was um would
have resonated with a lot of people uh
he's concerned about the children and
about the kids and it's sad to see that
you know when somebody tries their best
to be respectful to not yell not shout
didn't get very emotional or anything
but he's obviously you could sense the
care and concern that he has and he's
he's talking about it and then he's
going to be penalized even for speaking
even for just simply bringing up his
opinion uh that's very concerning so I
think I think the guy you know uh again
outside of one or two words that he used
which could have been a little bit you
know maybe better rehearsed he's he's
he's a hero I mean he's somebody where
other people should have the courage and
The Bravery to speak up and say what
their actual view is but not always but
what's happening people are being
bullied into silence and everyone's
afraid to to say anything
and that's if if everyone is afraid to
say something then we're just going to
continue to have more and more of this
cycle perpetuating situations is going
to get worse and worse you know I I was
listening to a community leader he was
touching upon kind of the same things he
was saying but he was quoting the
everybody knows potato chips are not
good for them everybody knows that
french fries aren't good for them they
know that cheesecakes not good for them
but nobody will dare speak out against
the Deviant sexual practice practices
that occur in this country and are not
only not talked about are promoted by
mainstream entertainment and Society
promoted deviant sexual practices that
are harmful to the human being
pathogenic sexual practices that cause
serious
diseases this isn't like a fatty food
that takes time many years before it
accumulates and causes a heart attack
this is a one-time possible death
sentence and yet people won't speak
honestly about it the World Health
Organization tells us that rectal
intercourse is the most risky form of
sexual
behavior that's what the World Health
Organization has to say and yet people
will not say this is not a healthy
choice I don't want my child to be
practicing this male or female this has
nothing to do with sexual preference
this has to do with a sexual practice
that is done amongst
heterosexual people and amongst
homosexual people yet it's harmful and
nobody wants to speak about
it we need our physicians to speak up
but the core point is coming back down
to the education right it's like is this
what we should be teaching children this
is somebody who's basically saying
listen guys Whoever has a family whoever
cares about family values whoever cares
about your children this is not
something that's healthy for children
it's not something that's good for
children whatever they decide later on
when they when they grow up you know
they can they can choose whatever they
want but to brainwash them at this young
age to to to swallow something which is
not generally historically recognized as
being natural or Universal or whatever
it is but then pushing it on them to say
no this is what we're going to make sure
that they do and you can't opt out and
you have no other option and and you
must accept every single thing that's
very problematic I mean adults want
don't want to hear this stuff I mean
people don't know like this is very
explicit you've read some of this you've
seen you've seen the books right I've
seen too many of the books unfortunately
it's really like cringe I mean this is
like very explicit where adults I mean
again going back to the boardroom people
in the boardroom they don't want to hear
this it affects me I've seen the second
grade books that I'm seeing I mean it's
talking about you know uh just it it's
at the level of pornography and like I
don't want to read that stuff forget my
kids I don't want to see that stuff why
should I have to see that why why don't
you put a if we had a rating system
right for the way we have for movies
they should put this book is rated R why
don't they have pornography in the
regular movie theaters then exactly EXA
why why not why not in a rated G why not
in a rated PG why don't why don't they
show exactly the same scene in a Disney
movie and I I hope they don't because it
wouldn't surprise me if Disney gets
there some yeah I'm not trying to give
them ideas you know would within 10
years 20 years it might be there but but
it's not there and that's the problem is
with double standards you got one
standard over here and you're like well
we have a rating system and we have
PG-13 or you know we have we have R and
we have all the other ratings that are
out there and they mean something and
some people actually check them and then
when it comes to the books because
there's political pressure coming in
from some other movement that's going to
basically blackmail you and say no but
this is going to end up in your book
where's the Parental Guidance the
parental guidance doesn't mean that
because your teacher is there it's all
of a sudden okay I mean I don't know
anyone says oh it's okay to watch rated
R movies in kindergarten because
technically your kindergarten teacher is
there and she's she's an adult or he's
an adult that happens to be there that
doesn't make it okay you it's funny
because the word says PG is Parental
Guidance it didn't say random adult
guidance right so that that's pretty
interesting I just thought about it
right now so I mean that's where people
need to wake up and say we have double
standards
let's have one consistent standard right
and and not just give not make
exceptions because there's going to be
one group that's going to threaten you
and say you need to do this otherwise
we're going to penalize you and that's
what's happening today and we need to be
on the side of Justice right be
transparent be fair be open and say what
your actual values are so we can
understand so the society can understand
don't make exceptions based on fear and
threats I think I've heard this from
from you the last time the count was at
it was at like 100 I forgot how many
genders oh yeah was like 107 last I
checked 107 107 yeah 107 this is the
last time you checked that last time I
checked like about a year and a half ago
maybe how did they get up to7 so you
know what's happening is that they're
trying to just invent as many words as
possible because the larger the number
the more it's going to confuse people
and think like wow there's so many man
manifestations of whatever the word
gender doesn't really mean anything
anymore the the dictionaries have been
redefined right they don't even every
every major dictionary in English has
been has changed the word gender if you
look 20 years ago and you look at what
it means now it doesn't mean anything
anymore so it's basically completely
relative so the more genders you add it
just confuses people and they're like
wow there's such a spectrum of diversity
of gender expression and what it means
and you come up with different words
some of the words are not from our
language they're borrowed from like
International you know different
countries uh of manifestation of what
this could be so that's just designed to
confuse people so that the way it got up
there was the same way that the alphabet
movement is become why we call it the
alphabet movement because it just keeps
on tacking more letters on and on there
so the more letters you get added you're
saying well this is part of the group
and this is part of the group and this
is part of it's all a part of the Q
group Q means queer and queer used to
mean weird right or strange and what
they they've done is that becomes the
umbrella term which represents anyone
that's not within the normal spectrum of
what human beings have always understood
the world to be when it comes to uh
attraction and when it comes to gender
right so anything on that spectrum is
basically considered to be queer so the
more letters you add the more it
confuses people and the more power it
seems like to have the more genders you
add the more it seems like gender must
be relative it's not not just two
because they just keep on adding more
and more and more and now you're like
how could the number get so high maybe
at least someone who's at least sticking
to their guns and saying no that doesn't
make sense there's only two genders or
two Sexes they're like okay maybe if
they're at a 100 maybe I could jump to
like three and if you can just jump to
three or four they got you that's all
they really wanted to do in the first
place all they wanted to do was just get
you beyond two to say that no gender is
not binary gender is not not just a male
and female no no there's there's there's
there's more than that and they can add
100 it's it's it's you they can add 100
and they just need you to add one from
that 100 they don't care about the other
99 and that's that's the the way it
works that's the gameing that's the game
wasn't this uh prophesized in the Quran
isn't this uh talks about that Shan will
change the creation Shan is going to
change the creation exactly exactly it's
going to cause people to make changes in
the creation of people so just the cre
he talking about physical creation now
it's not only changing the creation
you're changing the
definitions of creation like the very
definition so gender doesn't really have
any meaning anymore it's it's almost a
useless term so I mean science is just
being manipulated bought I mean at the
end of the day what is it uh because all
of this stuff that is in the biology
it's as it's like someone now you know
people get bent out of shape when you
got people and I and I there's there
probably more evidence not saying this
is I mean you know the people people who
argued Flat Earth right they could
probably make they make they have more
evidence that they they can make some
argument yeah ex exactly exactly you you
can manipulate things you can make an
argument and that that's the problem
science is viewed by the average person
as being something objective neutral not
being influenced by anything else but
but but but today it is but this is like
the most solid like this is something
that's being challenged that like again
in your DNA it's it's you just have to
look down when you go to the bathroom
it's just so black and white and it's
being questioned in a it's being
questioned it's it's it's I think people
not sticking to their principles people
following their desires uh not having a
good grounding in some type of divine
revelation or at least not having a
grounding in the idea that there's an
absolute morality people have basically
lost lost the idea that hey there's such
thing as real good and bad everything is
situational ethics in the minds of
people and that's part of the problem so
like what is it what does it mean to be
a good person what does it mean to be an
evil person would you say according to
uh what you're seeing are most people
that are going towards this are people
who just deny God
altogether uh I would say most of the
people are either very skeptical about
God and about any type of revealed
religion in general and then the second
strand are those people who internally
they're skeptical uh but they don't want
to openly say it so they're trying to
reframe and change their religion around
to accommodate and say no no no that's
that's not really what the verses say or
that's not really what the scripture was
saying and they're going to try to
basically twist around whichever
scripture it is whether it's the Quran
or it's the Bible or it's the Torah or
you know uh they're going to try and
twist it around so that it suits what
they want it to believe and that that's
that's what's the point of scripture
then if scripture is just going to be
something that fits whatever you want it
to fit and you're just going to
reinterpret anything whatever the way
that you want it's pretty much useless
if you're going to pick and choose tell
us bring us up to speed with this
Alberta recordings yeah so in Alberta uh
in in in Canada there was there was a
school that took place there was a
school where there was like a pride week
happening and many of the Muslims
they're like we don't want our kids to
see that Pride stuff so we're just going
to keep them out of school that week
they went back to school the next day
and one of the teachers took them to the
side these are mostly mostly Muslim
Students maybe it's all Muslim Students
and started just yelling at them and you
know thank God you know alhamdulillah we
say that one of the students took out
their phone and just started recording
so we have exactly the script of what
this teacher was saying and she's
yelling and screaming at them and saying
you know what you are so disrespectful
not coming to school and she says if you
believe basically she's saying if you
believe something is wrong with like
LGBT rainbow movement homosexuality
whatever it is you can't live here you
shouldn't be a Canadian citizen you
don't belong in this country you should
go somewhere else because we believe in
Freedom so ironic that she said that
right we believe in Freedom and if you
don't like that then you can't be here
because this is part of the law it was
so strange and then and then she starts
guilt tripping the Muslim kids and said
we celebrated your Eid and we celebrated
your Ramadan and you're not showing the
same amount of respect to you know the
LGBT people in in the in the school and
there there's a problem this is such you
know Muslims should not be tricked
nobody should be tricked into this line
of thinking there's two problems with
this argument problem number one is no
muslim has ever told anyone else that
you should celebrate Eid no no one goes
to school and say hey man hey hey John
hey hey hey Kathy if you're not wearing
a Eid Mubarak t-shirt then you're
disrespecting me as a Muslim but the
other way around if you don't wear that
rainbow tag on during Pride mon mon
you're not you're not an ally and if
you're not an ally that means you're a
homophobe and you're a bigot and you're
a this and you're a that so that's
number one number
two what look at the deal basically you
get to pick and choose any part of our
religion that you want and say we're
going to celebrate that because it fits
into our framework but in exchange what
do you have to do you have to change
your scripture any verse that we don't
like like the verse of the you know PE
uh people of prophet L Prophet lot all
the verses you know there's 105 verses
mentioned in the Quran about lot we want
you to change the interpretation of the
meaning of your book so we'll celebrate
we we'll put up a little uh you know
Crescent for Ramadan to show that you
know we're we're helping you celebrate
we're happy you're celebrating Ramadan
but you got in exchange you got to you
got to change your scripture you got to
change the Quran around what a horrible
deal that's a pretty sucky deal no one
should go with that deal so that's
what's happening and that's horrible
because you know what like imagine a kid
imagine a 10-year-old has to go to
school and their teacher going to
basically say like you shouldn't even
live in this country I mean that's
that's that's horrendous you know that
that's just that's straight up that's
Islam that's islamophobia that's
islamophobia coming from the political
left we experienced it from the
political right and now we're
experiencing from the political left
sadly that's a good point nobody's
telling anybody to celebrate Eid pray
five time I mean to have to implement
Islam not at all fast fast the whole
Ramadan if you want to you want to show
respect to us we're not asking you to
fast you know but then you go and you
see what they're what people are walking
around naked at grown men who are
walking around naked at these Pride
parades and the crazy thing is parents
who bring their children to
this that's the scary thing it's crazy
yeah yeah um have you been bullied at
all have you have you been attacked uh
you're there right in the heart of
everything have you had people who have
approached you have come to your mid and
uh we've had in our mjid not so much I
was at a protest once um it was against
the American Academy Pediatrics uh cuz
you know they're over medicalizing
children at this young age so yeah we we
got harassed by some
protesters uh it was pretty nasty you
know someone came and started uh you
know shouting us down uh turn around
stuck their rear end out in front of me
and in front of like one of the other
speakers mooned you yeah basically
mooned us yeah right there and it's just
like and for them that's like that's
their way of that's their way of
protesting you know so um yeah it was
really sad to see that uh so yeah I I've
I've been uh I've been the target of
that a little bit not not to the extent
I've had a YouTube video taken down uh
of some something that I said as well
other than that it's not been so bad
because I kind of have been staying
mostly uh within the uh space of the
Muslim community and teaming up on with
with uh you know religious folks
Christian Community the Jewish Community
uh on issues like this
particularly but I know if uh I were
invited to certain places dealing with
this topic there definitely would be a
lot more push back yeah but I'm kind of
privileged to be in a in a Masid
environment so I I I thank God for that
you know so there's a lot of uh rabbis
and other Christian uh priests and uh
people and the Christian Community who
are are working together with you on
this abely absolutely yes yes for sure
for sure and it's so nice to see that
because we didn't really have I mean we
had stuff to work on but we have not
been working on too many other issues
but now this issue is affecting
everybody and it's affecting their
children so now they're like you know
what whatever else is happening in other
parts of the world whatever other our
differences are this is something that's
affecting us right here in our own
Community let's let's team up on this
let's do something about it and I think
we should do something about it you know
what do you think people would say if
you had now many women who are
activating um who would be advocating
for uh children to be taught because now
there's not a lot of high value men
they're not being able to get married
and now they wanted uh people to get
educated on polygyny for example you
think they'd allow this in the schools
no way no no way huh absolutely no way
no I I think they would decriminalize or
at least they would normalize incest
before they would normalize polygyny
that's my view yeah yes this is my view
and unfortunately I see it leaning in
that direction you see what incest being
more normalized yeah yeah yeah they have
that uh what is it called minor
attracted uh peoples yeah yeah exact
some yeah one of these terms that came
out yeah so I mean so this what happens
when when you mess with sexuality and
you try to it it's just whatever feels
good and whatever follows your desires
you can go and turn this identity
politics and just saying this is how I
feel and my feelings turn into an
identity for me and we must respect
everyone's identity but identity based
on skin and based on ethnicity kind of
like what uh the brother was saying
that's different from Identity based on
your desires or your inclinations right
so if I'm an angry person I don't
identify as I'm an angry you know South
Asian Muslim man that's not part of your
you know that's that's not part of your
identity right that's just the the
feelings that you have so that's not the
way we look at these things so I have I
I I do see um this is probably going to
get a little bit worse before it starts
getting better think so yeah I think so
yeah yeah we never had that so people
just because someone feels a certain way
now today the person feels more feminine
now the person ends up wanting to uh
chop off a perfectly healthy body part
and we've seen have you seen you've seen
a lot of people who've gone down this
route and they're in a in a total um
state of now regret yeah it it's a it's
a
lifelong it's a life affecting decision
you know it's it's like when you get a
bunch of tattoos and then you regret and
you're like oh why did I get my you know
girlfriend or whoever's tattoo on my or
some verse or something and then you try
to remove it you can laser it off but
there's still going to be some marks
yeah when you when you start with the
hormones and when you start with the
surgery and you start cutting off parts
and you start taking one part cut off
and turn you know when you take a you
know not to get so explicit you take a
penis and turn it into a vagina or vice
versa or whatever it
is if you decide to go back because you
had a change of mind and there's
thousands of people who have a change of
mind and say we want to detransition
you're never going to be the same again
I've encountered dozens of people spoken
to them you spoken I've spoken to them
I've spoken to them I know about their
life story and the stuff that they tell
me that they wish they could have
children they wish they could go back to
their original voice that they used to
have they wish that uh you know the
effect that it had on their bones uh
would not be there I it it drains it
really you know you're playing with your
body and you can't go back to where you
originally should have normally been and
it's very dangerous it's very very
dangerous and the research is pretty
clear that it's it's almost like in
California when when when when people
were uh saying that you know cannabis is
legalized marijuana is is legalized for
medical purposes you could literally
walk into a doctor's office talk to them
for like 30 seconds and he'll issue you
a prescription and say you're good to go
so they just go and buy some marijuana
legally and just smok it and get high
the same thing is happening when it
comes to therapists you go and you say
you go to a therapist you have like one
session say you know I kind of feel like
I'm struggling with my gender identity
whatever it is they're going to give you
a prescription and be like you're you're
you're a good candidate for uh
testosterone or you're a good candidate
for any type of hormones you start the
hormone therapy or you're a good
candidate for puberty blockers you start
that and then from there you eventually
start to you start to feel different and
you're like oh wow I mean I this
experiences that I've had from people
that I've spoken to like one woman she's
like this is what it feels like to be a
guy she's pumping hormones into herself
she's like feel like this renewed sense
of confidence my muscles are growing I'm
this I'm that this is pretty cool this
is pretty interesting comes with some
you know downsides but this is this is
cool I'll try it out for a while and
then you just keep going and you keep
growing you going and then you do the
surgery and you do this and you do that
and you try and go back you change your
mind you're like what in the world was I
thinking you can't go back it's very
very hard to go back to where you were
before I mean it's not a permanent
change right but you're not going to be
the same person MH you you know and
that's scary man that's very scary mhm
life's never the same again never the
same again yeah never the same yeah so
then um if we go to um another aspect of
this is it seems like this is more of an
infringing on on women's uh rights also
women want to be in their own space and
the bathroom and even young kids sports
sports I mean have their own sports and
now men are coming anding they're
destroying all of their records mhm I
mean in swimming in track in everything
you just have a guy comes and identifies
his female whether or not they have
genuine you know uh diagnosed gender
dysphoria or not they can completely
shatter the world record of somebody who
you know all these women have been you
know putting in their whole life into
the sport to be able to do something and
then some you know trans athlete comes
and just shatter just destroys it
completely whether it's high school or
whether it's uh a world record or
something like that that's very very
concerning and it's very unfair and a
lot of women are very upset about that
and that's why they're like at least in
sports like draw some line and still
most politicians and most uh you know
people who are in positions of power
they won't even draw a line in sports
and that's very sad I mean just imagine
in in martial arts and things like that
I mean you're going to get some some
massive injuries you I mean the records
being broken injuries so many other
things that are happening kickboxing
things like that this is this is this is
where people like when we've gotten this
far right this is where people need to
start waking up and saying listen this
is too much like Glenn Greenwald you
know who himself is gay he's basically
saying it's gone too far the rest of the
American community and Canadians and
everyone else around the world needs to
realize it's gone too far it's time to
make a change now mhm and what's that
change what uh what can people do people
people need to start speaking up they
need to say listen this is not healthy
for our community this is not healthy
for our we're not going to keep on
making exceptions to uh something that
is nature we're not here to we're not
going to sit here we don't like bullying
anybody okay we just disagree with
somebody on whatever they're doing
morally we're not going to bully them
we're not going to call them names keep
keep those laws in place whatever small
laws like that are there that's fine but
to force everyone else to shift their
mentality to conform to over represent
in media and say you must have a quota
this many people you know from uh the
movement need to be within the main
characters of this film or that film uh
curriculum needs to be there and kids
need to be taught this we need to we
need to bring all that stuff back to
equilibrium and what it used to be and
stop pretending like there's this
massive uh keeping people in fear and
saying that you know
what if we don't do this then people are
going to die they're going to commit
suicide this is all this is false
propaganda like CNN just came up with an
article that was a travel advisory for
people in Canada who are LGBT they
should be careful of moving you know
traveling to America because they're
going to they're in serious danger it's
such an exaggeration it's it's it's it's
it's political propaganda we need to
stop the exaggeration we people need to
speak up and say we're tired of this
false propaganda the way that people
were people who were had a little people
of
conscious uh they were speaking out when
there was propaganda on war in Iraq and
they're like come on man you really got
uh proof of chemical chemical weapons
and weapons of mass destruction and all
that whenever you see something false in
the media people should wake up and they
should say hey we're tired of that we
know that's false stop trying to you
know trick us and brainwash us for
whatever political objective you have so
when people need to wake up today it
means people need to wake up and say
listen these aren't the real facts you
know this is this is an exaggeration
it's over representation there's a
minority uh group that happens to be in
very high positions of power that are
pressuring you to do all of this this
needs to stop I even Fox News few months
ago I mean during pride month I couldn't
believe it Fox News of all places has
got like a thing on their website about
like Pride flags and we're celebrating
Pride I'm like what where is where's the
where's the values and the ethics that
you guys were supposed to have
represented or at least you you know
people Affiliated you with Associated
you with so people need to come back to
their core values stop being afraid to
speak up and say we're going to speak
the truth because if we don't then
there'll be nobody left to speak the
truth MH and you you gave an example of
someone who came to listen to one of
your talks one time and I think later on
they came they had had um they were
inclined towards a certain lifestyle and
you remember the story that is Ellie
Kelly and Ellie maybe I forgot the the
yeah someone who became Muslim and she
had a partner okay yes was calply Pomona
yes this was in a university yeah yeah
so what happened with that I mean so
this actually the person end up shifting
their lifestyle they were inclined
towards their desires a certain way yeah
and then they listened to one of your
talks and what happened with yeah so I
mean she came they were you know there
were there were there were lesbian
couple inside the University and um you
know they were one at least one of them
was genuinely interested in learning
about Islam so she came to an intro to
Islam and said you know I'm really
interested in learning more I don't
really know much about this religion so
I explained what are the principles of
Islam and everything like that and then
I found out like a few months later that
uh you know she broke up with her
girlfriend and she went through a really
tough time and she's like well Islam
seems like a really nice religion and it
seems to make sense to me and I'm going
through something in my life so she
became Muslim and then she became Muslim
and then she started wearing hijab you
know she started putting on the head
scarf and everything and she gave up
pork and all of that stuff and I
remember you know speaking uh with uh I
think it was with her with somebody next
to her saying you know the most
difficult thing for me in in my life to
give up giving up pork was easy and
wearing the hijab was easy and starting
the five days you know five times prayer
all of that stuff was not the biggest
challenge for me the biggest challenge
was being able to give up my identity of
being a lesbian and being gay but she's
saying but I did it for Allah and that
was just it so powerful for me I I
didn't realize like how challenging that
would be most people are like you know
pork oh man I miss those you know bacon
burgers or whatever it is or you know
wearing a hijab is really hard people
are going to be staring at you but for
her it's like this was a core part of my
identity that's kind of the way she grew
up
and she's like but I realized that even
though it was once I realized that this
is not what God wants and internally she
probably knew that something is also not
right about it she goes I'm going to
adjust my lifestyle in a way that I know
is better for me even though it's hard
and I think that's that's a huge lesson
for everybody is that you know it can be
really tough changing your life can be
really tough but when it's for the right
cause and it's actually going to be good
for you in this life as well as in the
next life
then you do it m you do it and and and
God will make it easy for you can we say
now that I mean as Muslims uh we we we
love for Humanity what we love for
ourselves so we want good for Humanity
want we want to protect the children uh
we're doing this out of the love and if
somebody has a certain lifestyle if they
would consider this way of life I mean
uh if they evaluate themselves and see
where they're at right now are they are
they truly in contempt um uh in peace uh
are they truly are there is that void
filled is are they ha happy in a sense
that they're going through life um you
know feeling that their purpose is being
met I mean and then they compare it to
what they can get here like this person
uh that you gave the story about I mean
they've considered and it seems like
people when they follow desires you just
try one thing that doesn't bring you any
kind of a contentment you go to the next
thing and then you just keep going you
keep climbing the ladder you keep going
going and just like many of these people
you talking about then they make this
decision Shayan takes you to the point
of no return now but and while you're
alive there's always hope isn't there
there's always a point that you can go
ahead and and return to your maker to
your creator and that's where that void
gets filled that's where you get that
contentment that's where you get that
Solace joy and happiness exactly that's
that's exactly what it is until your
life is over you always have an
opportunity to make that change and when
you make that change you feel you feel
the difference in your life you know you
when you live with purpose and an
objective purpose not just a purpose you
define for yourself to run around and
just eat drink and be merry but when you
when you have when you understand why
you've been created and why you're here
just that in and of itself brings you a
type of Solace and contentment in your
life that you're not going to find
anywhere else mhm thank you thank you
for spending some time with us pleas
going over this uh hopefully we can uh
make a difference make a change do our
small part and um if there's anybody who
wants to um if you have some Christians
uh some other people of other uh faiths
Consciousness and they're in your area
or they they want to speak out they want
to go ahead and unify so we can have uh
a stronger voice uh what do you advise
them yeah yeah I mean they can reach out
to me uh reach out to any of the uh uh
Muslim leadership uh we'd love to work
with you uh my contact information is
easily available just type my name in
yeah
justad
brother
this is I've known brother Eddie and the
de show for many many years and as a
matter of fact I was one of the original
people who showed up on his show
alhamdulillah and he's been doing a
great job alhamdulillah in spreading the
de of Allah subhana wa through his show
through his activities and da right now
they're working alhamdulillah on a great
project uh the dean Center which is now
taking this da from such a small show to
become a mega program weate the de of
Allah subhana to larger audience and
they need your support and I give them
my support in
for the dean Center hopefully in you can
look into it and put some uh running
charity and walk for yourself in in this
project that brings you continuous
charity for the rest of your life until
the day of judgment support the dean
[Music]
Center I cannot leave without giving you
a gift if you're not yet Muslim and
you're tuning in to see what these
Muslims are talking about and you like a
free copy of the Quran go ahead and
visit theen show.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum